HE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TING NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. ARAMBULA OUR K.
HERE SENATE BERMAN BIGELOW BLOOM
. BONTA BRIAN CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES JUNE CHOI COOLEY
COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY DAILY
BABIES LARA MICROPHONE VINCE
FONG FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GREAT GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA KILEY
LACKEY LEAD LEVINE LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN MURATSUCHI THIS
AREA NGUYEN. DONALD LISTEN
PETRIE-NORRIS QUOTE QUIRK-SILVA
RAMOS REYES THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SEYARTO SMITH STONE
TEAM BELLA. BE APPROVED ROCK
VOEPEL WALDRON WARD WEBER WICKS
WILSON WOOD MISTER SPEAKER.
WHAT. MEMBERS A QUORUM IS
PRESENT WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND
VISITORS IN THE REAR OF THE
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY TO
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER THE
DAYS PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED BY
OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN IMAM YASIR
KHAN. YOU MOM YESTERDAY. IN THE
NAME OF GOD. THE MOST GRACIOUS
THE MOST MERCIFUL. ALMIGHTY AND
CREATOR GOD. THE SUN NEVER SETS
ON YOUR WORLD. AND IT IS ALWAYS
RISING ON YOUR PEOPLE. THEREFORE
WE ARE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
STEADFAST LOVE AND MERCY. THAT
IS THAT IS AVAILABLE TO US AGAIN
TODAY. WE ASSIGN OUR GRATITUDE
TO YOU FOR THE BLESSINGS ALL
AROUND US. THAT WE ARE SO
FREQUENTLY. NOW WE SO FREQUENTLY
MISTAKE AS THE RESULT OF OUR OWN
EFFORTS AND TALENTS. AND BE FREE
. LOOK KINDLY ON YOUR PEOPLE WHO
SEEK HEALTH. AND HOPE AND THE
PROMISE OF A BETTER DAY. GIVE
YOUR FAVOR TO THE SUFFERING THE
SORROWFUL AND THE DISTRESSED.
YOU HAVE MADE FOR ALL OF US. IN
WHICH WE ARE TO LIVE WORK AND
MAKE PEACE. LET US REJOICE AND
BE GLAD IN IT I MEAN. THANK YOU
MOM WE ASK OUR GUESTS TO
CONTINUE TO STAND AS WE ENGAGE
IN THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LORI WILSON AS
SHE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS
ONE NATION UNDER GOD INDIVISIBLE
WITH LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL
. YO MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY GERMAN SACRAMENTO
TUESDAY MARCH TWENTY NINE TWENTY
TWENTY TO THE ASSEMBLY MET AT
SEVEN AM THE AMAKHOSI ARE TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SIXTY SEVEN JUST
PRESIDING CHIEF WORKS YOU
PROGRAM THE BEST READY FOR DAVID
. AND MR GALLAGHER SECONDS THAT
THEY'RE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH
PRESENTATIONS AND PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION AND
REFERENCE OF BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM THE
SENATE THERE ARE NONE. MOVING ON
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS. THE
ABSENCES FOR TODAY FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOLEY FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES. MISSED REYES YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK FOR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
MEDINA MYSELF EDUARDO GARCIA
CERVANTES RUBIO GIPSON AND
PETRIE-NORRIS TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FIFTY SIX AND JOINT RULE SIXTY
TWO AA TO ALLOW THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB TWENTY
FORTY THREE. JONES SAWYER FOR
THEIR MEAT FOR THEIR HEARING ON
TUESDAY APRIL NINETEENTH PENDING
REFERRAL FROM THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX TO ALLOW
FOLLOWING THE FOLLOWING
COMMITTEES TO NOTICE BILLS
PENDING REFERRAL FROM OTHER
COMMITTEES. TO ALLOW THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB TWENTY
EIGHT THIRTY BLOOM FOR THEIR
HEARING ON TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY
SIXTH. PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE AND THAT TO
ALLOW THE BANKING AND FINANCE
COMMITTEE TO NOTICE AB WENTY
TWO FIFTY EIGHT WOULD IT. FOR
THEIR HEARING ON MONDAY APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH PENDING REFERRAL
FROM THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA. THE TWO
DAY FILE NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO
ALLOW THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE. TO HEAR
AB SEVENTEEN OH FOUR JAM. AT
THEIR HEARING ON TUESDAY APRIL
NINETEENTH. WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER.
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX I
REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE
REFER TO THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE. AB SEVENTEEN NINETY
ONE NAZARIAN AND FOR THE REVENUE
AND TAXATION COMMITTEE. TO THE
HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. AB
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN WILSON FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
. TO THE HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWO WOULD FROM THE HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
TO THE BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. AB TWENTY SIX OH TWO
SALAS FROM TRANSPORTATION
COMMITTEE TO HUMAN SERVICES
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE AND-
THREE TWO DEVELOPMENTS COMMITTEE
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. FINALLY AT THE
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM FIFTY NINE EIGHTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
BOERNER HORVATH FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE CLERK WILL KNOW.
MEMBERS. MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY TODAY ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER DADDY YO
PLEASE WELCOME COUNCILMEMBER
MITCH O'FARRELL FROM THE
THIRTEENTH DISTRICT IN LOS
ANGELES. ALSO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GOING TO EUROPE
PLEASE WELCOME LOS ANGELES AREA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE PRESIDENT
AND CEO MARIA SALINAS. AND BOARD
CHAIR MARK. NINE WELCOME TO THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WE HAVE A
FORMER MEMBER OF THE ASSEMBLY
WITH US TODAY ON THE FLOOR
PLEASE WELCOME. SUSAN BERNIE
YEAH. WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GUESTS
IN THE GALLERY TODAY PLEASE
WELCOME THE PHARMACIST INTERNS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS
ASSOCIATION. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEAVE ALSO HAS GUESTS IN THE
GALLERY TODAY THERE STUDENT
JOURNALISTS AND INFLUENCERS FROM
FREMONT PLEASE WELCOME AMELIA
AND EGINA D'ELEGANCE VIA.
MOVING ON TO BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE. SECOND READING. FILE
ITEMS ONE THROUGH NINETEEN ARE
PASSED IN OR CHANGE. SORRY AT
FILE ITEMS WENT TO NINETEEN THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE OH SIX TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO WITH A MINUTE SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SIX OF THE MEMBERS
TWENTY SIXTY ONE OF THE BEST
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE FOR THE
BUSINESS TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY
SEVEN WITH A WOMEN'S TWENTY SIX
NINETY SIX OF THE MEMBERS TWENTY
FIVE ANY THREE WITH ELEVEN
SIXTEEN FIFTY TWO TWENTY THREE
THIRTY SEVEN. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT WITH A MINUTES NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE WITH A BEVERAGE
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE THE
MEMBERS TWENTY THIRTY EIGHT
MINUTES TWENTY TWO FIFTY ONE OF
THE MEMBERS TWENTY THREE TWENTY
WITH ELEVEN SEVENTEEN- FOR THE
MEMBERS TWENTY FIVE NINETY THREE
FOR THE BUSINESS AND ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN FIFTY THREE
MINUTES. ALL BILLS WILL BE
DEEMED. AND AMENDMENTS. WILL BE
DEEMED ADOPTED. MOVING ON TO THE
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. FILE
ITEMS TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR.
WILL BE PASSED ENTERTAINED. WE
WILL MOVE ON IT NOW. TO FILE
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. SORRY THE CLERK WILL
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON AN ACT RELATING TO
MENTAL HEALTH. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PATTERSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED AT
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND- MEMBERS IN TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR THE VOTERS ENACTED
PROPOSITION. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER IN TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
THE VOTERS ENACTED PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE WHICH ESTABLISHED
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WHICH WAS TAXED TO
OVERSEE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT.
AS IT CURRENTLY STANDS THE
COMMISSION LACKS REPRESENTATION
IN THE NORTHERN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY THE INLAND EMPIRE AND THE
ORANGE COUNTY REGION. THE BILL
BEFORE YOU AB SIXTEEN OF SIXTY
EIGHT URGES THE GOVERNOR WHEN
MAKING APPOINTMENTS TO THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION.
TO ENSURE THAT ALL TEN REGIONS
OF CALIFORNIA AS DEFINED BY THE
TWENTY TWENTY SENSES ARE IN FACT
REPRESENTATIVE. EACH OF OUR
DISTRICTS HAD VARIOUS MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS AND THE REP
REPRESENTATION- THAT THE
COMMISSION PROVIDES SHOULD NOT
BE ANY DIFFERENT AB SIXTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT WILL ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIANS WITH MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES ARE APPROPRIATELY
REPRESENTED. AND ARE ABLE TO GET
THE KIND OF HELP THAT THEY NEED
A TAILORED TO THE PARTICULAR
NEEDS AND CONCERNS OF THEIR AREA
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THEIR OWN. ALL THOSE VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTE
YOU DESIRE TO GO. ALL THOSE
VOTER THE DESIRE TO VOTE. LOCAL
CLOSE THE ROLE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE AND TALLY THE
VOTES. I SIXTY TWO KNOWS ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
TWENTY SIX AND TWENTY SEVEN OUR
PASTORAL CHANGE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT THE CLERK
WILL READ A. B. SIXTEEN FIFTY
SIX THE CLERK WILL READ SOME
PEOPLE SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AN
ACT LEADING THE CANNABIS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I GET CURRY ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX LEGISLATION
THAT CLARIFIES THAT THE ADULT
USE CANNABIS INITIATIVE PASSED
BY THE CALIFORNIA VOTERS IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND THE
MEDICINAL AND ADULT USE CANNABIS
REGULATION SAFETY ACT DOES NOT
PROHIBIT A DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LICENSEE FOR
MANUFACTURING DISTRIBUTING OR
SELLING PRODUCTS THAT CONTAIN
INDUSTRIAL HEMP. OR CANNABIS
NOISE EXTRACTS DERIVATIVES FROM
THE INDUSTRIAL HIM THE STATE O
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST CBD MARKET THE UNITED
STATES DESPITE PASSAGE OF AB
FORTY FIVE LAST YEAR THERE ARE
STILL QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT IS
LEGAL AND YOU COULD PRODUCE CBD
PRODUCTS IN THE NEW MARKET
PLACE. IT RECENTLY ISSUED
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH FAQ HAS
SOMEWHAT MUDDIED THE WATERS BY
INCORRECTLY STATING THAT OUT OF
STATE MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO REGISTER IN
CALIFORNIA. AB SIXTEEN FIFTY SIX
REPRESENTS A REFINEMENT OF LAST
YEAR'S BILLS LEGISLATION TO
FURTHER OUTLINED A DEFINED AND
STABLE REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT
FOR LICENSED CBD PRODUCTS. OF
ALL OF THE STATE. AB SIXTEEN
FIFTY SIX ALSO STATES
LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO EVENTUALLY
ENHANCE THE VIABILITY OF
CANNABIS LICENSEES IN THE
MARKETPLACE BY PRESERVING A
PURSUING MEASURES TO RELIEVE TAX
AND REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS. AND
TO AUTHORIZE LICENCES TO
MANUFACTURE DISTRIBUTE AND SELL
HIM ACCOUNTABLE NORTH POLITICS
INCOME IN COMPLIANCE WITH
CURRENT LAW WE EAGERLY. AWAIT
THE RELEASE BY JULY ONE OF A
REPORT BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL THAT WILL
OUTLINE THE NEEDED STEPS TO
INCORPORATE HIM TO THE CALIBER
MUST SUPPLY CHAIN. I ANTICIPATE
AMENDING THIS BILL IN LIGHT OF
BUSINESS THE PROFESSIONALS
COMMITTEE MAY WISH TO HEAR THE
BILL AGAIN IN ITS FINAL FORM
WHEN IT COMES BACK THE ASSEMBLY
FOR CONCURRENCE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL. SEEING AND HEARING NO
DEBATE. AT WE WILL MOVE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THOSE
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE ALL THOSE
VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
WELL CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE
VOTES. HIGHS FIFTY ONE KNOWS TO
THE MEASURE PASSES. WILL MOVE ON
TO FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE THIS IS
AN EMERGENCY BILL AB TWO TWO
NINE BY THREE OF US. THREE OF US
YOU RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR DESK.
THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY TO TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LUIS REBOUNDS AND
ACTUALLY THE PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
DECLARE THE URGENCY THERE UP
SIGNIFICANTLY MYSTERY THAT'S
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AB TWO TWO
TWO NINE AS A SIMPLE CLEAN UP
BILL I'M TO CORRECT A DRAFTING
ERROR LAST YEAR I AUTHORED AB
TEN NINETY SIX WHICH REMOVES THE
INAPPROPRIATE TERM ALIEN FROM
OUR STATE CODES. DURING THE FALL
I CAME TO MY STAFF'S ATTENTION
THAT THE ORIGINAL DRAFTING
VERSION OF AB TEN NINETY SIX WAS
BASED ON THE OLD VERSION OF
GOVERNMENT SANCTIONED. TEN
THIRTY ONE THIS BILL WILL JUST
SIMPLY CORRECT THAT- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. SEEING AND HEARING NO
DEBATE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL THOSE VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE MEMBERS THIS IS AN
EMERGENCY BILL REQUIRING TWO
THIRDS VOTE. HIGHS FIFTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES ON
THE URGENCY IS FIFTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO. THE CLERK WILL CLOSER ALL
. I FIFTY EIGHT NO ZERO I KNOW
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES ON
URGENCY MEASURE PASSES AS WELL.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM IT NUMBER
TWENTY AT THIRTY WHICH IS AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY FIVE
PASSENGER TRAINS MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD THE CLERK WILL READ. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD NATURALLY
THE VITAL RECORDS. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHAT DO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
SIX SIMPLY INCREASES THE TIME TO
REGISTER A LIVE BIRTH WITH THE
LOCAL REGISTRAR FROM WITHIN TEN
DAYS TO TWENTY ONE DAYS AFTER
THE BIRTH OF A CHILD. PROVIDENCE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY INITIATED A
BETTER BIRTHING PROJECT WITH
LOCAL TRIBES AND ONE IMPORTANT
ISSUE IDENTIFIED WAS THAT MANY
NATIVE FAMILIES. WE STOP. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- PROVIDENCE
HUMBOLDT COUNTY INITIATED A
BETTER BIRTHING PROJECT WHICH
WITH LOCAL TRIBES IN ONE
IMPORTANT ISSUE IDENTIFIED WAS
THAT MANY NATIVE AMERICAN
FAMILIES- FOLLOW CULTURAL
TRADITION OF NOT NAMING THEIR
NEWBORN FOR TEN DAYS TO ALLOW
FOR A SACRED CEREMONIAL BLESSING
FOR THE FAMILY CHOOSES THE NAME
OF THE NEW BORN. CURRENT LAW
REQUIRES A HOSPITAL SET TO
SUBMIT A BABY'S BIRTH
CERTIFICATE TO THE LOCAL
REGISTRAR WITHIN TEN DAYS THIS
REQUIREMENTS PUTS UNDUE PRESSURE
ON THE FAMILY DOES NOT TAKE
THEIR CULTURAL CONSIDERATIONS-
TRADITIONS INTO CONSIDERATION
NATIVE AMERICANS HAVE THE
INHERENT RIGHT TO EXERCISE OUR
SPIRITUAL AND CULTURAL
TRADITIONS IN AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY SIX WILLIMON EIGHT ONE
BUREAUCRATIC OBSTACLE ON
TRADITIONAL PRACTICES. OF THOSE
AN INDIGENOUS TO NORTH AMERICA.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOOD MISTER PROMISE YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER I
ALSO RISE AS A PROBLEM CO AUTHOR
OF AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY SIX.
WHEN LIFE IS BROUGHT INTO THIS
WORLD IT IS A SPECIAL TIME.
EXTENDING CALIFORNIA'S TIMELINE
FOR REGISTERING NEW BURST FROM
TEN DAYS TWENTY ONE DAYS THIS
ALLOWS NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES
LIKE THE EUROPE PEOPLE- TO
PRACTICE THEIR CULTURE AND TO
FULFILL. THEIR CULTURAL NAMING
TRADITIONS. WHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HONORS CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST PEOPLE. THEIR RIGHTS TO
THEIR RIGHT TO HOLD THEIR NAMING
CEREMONIES THAT TAKES UP TO
TWENTY ONE DAYS THIS COMES AS A
WAY TO HONOR CALIFORNIA'S FIRST
PEOPLE AND THE RIGHTS. OF
CALIFORNIA FIRST PEOPLE IN FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO HONOR
THAT I APPLIED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD FOR INTRODUCING THIS
MEASURE WHICH MAKES OUR STATE
MORE RESPECTFUL OF THE
CALIFORNIA INDIAN PEOPLE I URGE
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
DEBATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHAT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE VOTE
AND THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
BERNADINO COUNTY TO OFFER HIS
SUPPORT. ALL THE BIG HAVING
SEIZE THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE
VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTES. LOCAL
CLOSER ROLE IN TALLY THE VOTES.
I SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE WILL MOVE ON
NOW TO THIRTY TWO THREE FILE
ITEM THIRTY TWO THROUGH THIRTY
FIVE WHICH OUR PASTOR CHANGE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SIX AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY EIGHTY BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN IMMACULATE
IN THE CORPORATIONS IN THE CAR
THE UC THERE UP TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHENEY ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR WOMEN PERCENT AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY CURRENTLY
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS THE
CORPORATION FROM CONDUCTING A
MEETING SHAREHOLDERS REMOTELY.
THIS BILL AB SEVENTY EIGHTY
WOULD BUILD UPON THE L. AND ALSO
PRESENT WERE DETERMINED THAT A
MEETING MAY BE CONDUCTED FIRSTLY
RATHER JUST IN PERSON. THANK YOU
IN A RESERVE CLASS PRIVATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO DEBATE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THE GLOBE
IN THE ROLE. ALL THOSE VOTING
TODAY TO VOTE ALL THOSE GREATLY
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL THOSE Mí
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLLING TELEVOTERS. I SIXTY
TWO KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES. AT I. SIXTY TWO NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I SIXTY TWO NO
ZERO THE THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THE
CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AND I
BELIEVE INTO THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
THANK YOU MADAM IS THE SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY ONE WILL AUTHORIZE THE
BOARD TO START ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM AND ALLOW
THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT BOARD AND
COMMITTEE MEETING SCHEDULED TO
BECOME MORE EFFICIENT. UNDER
EXISTING LAW BOARD MEMBERS CAN
ONLY BE REIMBURSED FOR TRAVEL TO
MEETINGS LIKE. RIGHT ZERO PUBLIC
TRANSIT BUT NOT BY WALKING OR
BIKING CURRENTLY THE BOARD
MEMBERS CAN ONLY BE A BURST OF
THE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER DAY FOR
ATTENDING ONE OR MULTIPLE
MEETINGS AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
ONE ALLOWS THE BOARD TO CREATE
AN ACTIVE TRANSPORTATION
PROGRAM. THAT COMPENSATES
MEMBERS FOR BIKING OR WALKING TO
MEETINGS WHICH IS IN LINE WITH
CALIFORNIA'S EMISSION REDUCTION
GOALS. SEKALI AS RIVAL. THANK
YOU SEEING AND HEARING AT NO
FURTHER DEBATE. THE CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. THERE TO VOTE ALL
THOSE VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE TO DESIRE TO VOTE. HER BOOK CLOSER ROLAND TALLY
THE VOTES. HI SIXTY KNOWS TO.
NOT VOTING FIFTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER THIRTY EIGHT AB TWO SIX
ONE ONE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIX ELEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND
ACTIVATING THE BUSINESSES. MR
DALY ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS. THIS BILL CREATES A
STANDARD DEFINITION IN STATUTE
FOR A FAMILY OWNED BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS STANDARD
DEFINITION WILL PROVIDE CLARITY
FOR POLICY MAKERS IN THE FUTURE
WHEN MAKING ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
DECISIONS INCLUDING TAX POLICY
GRANT PROGRAMS AND EMPLOYEE
TRAINING INCENTIVES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO DEBATE THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. ALL
THOSE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL THOSE VOTE TO DECIDE TO VOTE
. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES. HIGHS FIFTY
EIGHT NO ZERO NINE THIRTEEN
NINETEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE WILL BE
PASS AND RETAIN. FILE ITEM FORTY
AND FORTY ONE PASS AND RETAIN.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY TWO
AJ ARE SEVENTEEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALK WARRANT AT WALDRON CLERK
WILL READ. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVENTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON RELATIVE TO
MILITARY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. MISS WALDRON NEAR RECOGNIZING
YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE
TO PRESENT THE MILITARY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE. THANK
YOU. I RISE TO PRESENT AJ ARE
SEVENTEEN THE MILITARY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE JOINT
RESOLUTION THIS RESOLUTION URGES
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO HELP
THOSE WHO SERVED OUR COUNTRY
FIGHT ONE OF THE HARDEST BATTLES
IN THEIR LIVES WHEN THEY COME
HOME. ADRIEN BRONER WAS ONE OF
THOSE SOLDIERS WHO NEEDED HELP.
THIS RESOLUTION HAS SPECIAL
MEANING FOR ME. AS THE BONNER
FAMILY OR SPECIAL PERSONAL
FRIENDS. AGENTS SERVED THREE
TOURS IN IRAQ BEFORE BEING
HONORABLY DISCHARGED. HIS
FRIENDS AND FAMILY WOULD
DESCRIBE HIM AS AN OUTSTANDING
SOLDIER AND THE TYPE OF FRIEND
THAT WAS ALWAYS MAKING PEOPLE
LAUGH. HOWEVER AFTER RETURNING
HOME FROM SERVING HIS COUNTRY
ADMIRABLY AND FAITHFULLY. HE
WOULD EXPERIENCE POSTTRAUMATIC
STRESS DISORDER AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE PROBLEMS. ADRIAN SOUGHT
OUT TREATMENT BUT UNFORTUNATELY
FELL VICTIM TO THE OBSTACLES AND
DELAYS TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT. THAT
MANY OF HIS FELLOW SOLDIERS
STILL EXPERIENCE. IF TREATMENT
FOR VETERANS WERE MORE READILY
ACCESSIBLE SOLDIERS LIKE ADRIEN
BRONER COULD AVOID THE DANGEROUS
LIFE OF ADDICTION THAT
ULTIMATELY LED TO HIS TRAGIC
DEATH. HIS BODY WAS FOUND UNDER
AN OVERPASS IN ESCONDIDO. HAVING
BEEN SENSELESSLY MURDERED. A
TWENTY SIXTEEN REPORT FOUND THAT
VETERANS WHO SERVED IN IRAQ AND
AFGHANISTAN ACCOUNT FOR THE
GREATEST NUMBER OF MENTAL HEALTH
DIAGNOSES IN THE VETERANS HEALTH
ADMINISTRATION THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS
ALONE HAVE TRACKED MORE THAN
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND VETERANS
WITH OPIOID DISORDERS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. YET WAIT TIMES FOR
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES CONTINUE
TO BE EX AGAIN IF I CAN
IMPEDIMENT TO EFFECTIVE CARE.
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDERS ARE SERIOUS AND TRAGIC
PUBLIC HEALTH PROBLEM THAT CAN
BE IMPROVED THROUGH INCREASED
AWARENESS RESOURCES AND PROPER
TREATMENT. AJ ARE SEVENTEEN
NAMED FOR MY FRIEND ADRIEN
BONNER. URGES THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS AND
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS TO TAKE ALL MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT MILITARY VETERANS
CAN ACCESS NECESSARY TREATMENT.
FOR MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS IN A TIMELY
MANNER WE MUST KEEP FIGHTING FOR
VETERANS LIKE ADRIEN BRONER WHEN
THEY ARE HOME. I RESPECTFULLY
URGE AN AYE VOTE AND WOULD
REQUEST THAT THE FIRST ROLE BE
OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON MISS
QUIRK-SILVA YOUR RECOGNIZE IT
WOULD ASK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER I RISE TODAY ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF A J. R. SEVENTEEN
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DO YOU DISORDERS ARE A
SERIOUSPROBLEM THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA'S GENERAL POPULATION
. UNFORTUNATELY DATA SHOWS THAT
ACTIVE DUTY SERVICE MEMBERS AND
VETERANS EXPERIENCE THESE ISSUES
AT A MUCH HIGHER RATE THAN THOSE
WHO HAVE NOT SERVED IN THE
MILITARY. LADIES AND GENTLEMAN.
WE SEND OUR YOUNG WOMEN. AND MEN
OFF TO SERVICE AND MANY TIMES
THEY RETURN AND THEY NEED OUR
SUPPORT AND OFTEN EXCESSIVELY IN
THESE TYPES OF VITAL SERVICES
COMES AT A HUGE COST MANY MANY
BARRIERS AS WE KNOW TO GETTING
THOSE APPOINTMENTS GETTING THE
TREATMENT AND WE KNOW THAT THEY
NEED AND IT DOES NOT COME IN A
TIMELY MANNER WE MUST PRIORITIZE
VETERAN MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDERS THAT
CONTINUE TO TAKE THE LIVES OF
THOSE WHO HAVE PROTECTED AND
SERVED OUR COUNTRY. PLEASE JOIN
ME IN SUPPORTING OUR SERVICEMEN
AND WOMEN AND VETERANS AND
SUPPORTING AJ ARE SEVENTEEN.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK-SILVA SEEING IN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER VOEPEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THE RISE IN
SUPPORT OF A J. SEVENTEEN- I'VE
LIVED THIS I KNOW IT. AND THIS
BILL IS SPOT ON WE WILL NOT
BUILD BUT- IT IS NEEDED. M. THE
VETERANS ADMINISTRATION AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. LIKE MANY
ORGANIZATIONS DOES NOT TREAT
MENTAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE WITH THE- NEED THAT IT
MUST HAVE SO. SEND A MESSAGE
THANK YOU. MISTER MATHIS YOU
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AGAIN MEMBERS. ONE VETERANS GET HOME. WE'RE
HANDED A BOOK. SIZE EIGHT FONT
HERE'S YOUR BENEFITS WELCOME
HOME GOOD LUCK. GO TO THE VA.
THAT'S IT. THAT IS THE REALITY.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU GET OUT OF
JAIL. WE MAKE SURE YOU GOT ALL
YOUR BENEFITS YOU'VE GOT YOUR-
THANK SET UP TO GO TO THE
PHARMACY VERY THING SET UP TO GO
TO THE DOCTOR YOU'VE GOT FOOD
STAMPS YOU'VE GOT CASH AND
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO. IF YOU'RE
GETTING OUT OF JAIL. IF YOU'RE
GETTING OUT OF THE MILITARY.
YEAH I GET A BOOK. IN A WELCOME
HOME AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE ADEBOYE. THAT NEEDS TO
CHANGE. A. G. R. SEVENTEEN IS A
STEP TO DO THAT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER DEBATE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WALDRON YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF- MY FRIEND AGENT
BONNER IN THE BONNER FAMILY AND
SO MANY THOUSANDS OF OTHERS JUST
LIKE HIM I URGE AN IPHONE. THIS
WALDRON HAS ASKED THAT THE FIRST
ROLE BE OPENED FOR CO AUTHORS
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
ALL THOSE VOTE YOU DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL THOSE Mí
VOTE. ALL THOSE WITH THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE FOR CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS
WE HAVE SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS.
ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL
NOT TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION. THE CLERK WILL OPEN
THEIR ON THE RUN. A DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLE
AND TALLY THE VOTES. I SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT RESERVE
RESOLUTION PASSES.
FILE ITEMS FORTY THREE THROUGH
FIFTY TWO OUR PASSENGERS CHANGE. MOVING ON TO THE THIRD READING
OF A SENATE BILLS. FILE ITEMS
FIFTY THREE THROUGH FIFTY FIVE
OUR PASTOR RETAINED. IN MANY
SERIOUS DISCOURSE. OKAY JUST.
ONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
COMMENCEMENT KERN I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX AND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO AA TO ALLOW
THE INSURANCE COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE AB TWENTY FORTY THREE
JONES SAWYER. FOR THE HEARING ON
WEDNESDAY APRIL TWENTIETH
PENDING REFERRAL FROM THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE. WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE SEVERAL
COMMITTEE HEARINGS THIS
AFTERNOON IN OUR ANNOUNCEMENTS
SECTION THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES WILL MEET AT TWO
THIRTY IN ROOM FOUR FORTY SEVEN
THE COMMITTEE ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION WILL MEET AT TWO THIRTY
IN ROOM ONE TWENTY SIX THE
COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION WILL
MEET AT TWO THIRTY. IN THE SWING
SPACE ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED AND
THE COMMITTEE ON BANKING AND
FINANCE WILL MEET AT THREE
THIRTY IN ROOM FOR FORTY FOUR.
MEMBERS THE QUORUM CALL IS NOW
LIFTED. WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. MEMBERS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS AND GIVE
YOUR RESPECTFUL ATTENTION OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
ARE TAKER CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO THE
FOLLOWING MEMBERS WHO HAVE GRANT
WHO HAVE BEEN GRANTED PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON AN
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MEDINA. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF DR ODD MONDO NEVADA.
DR NEVADA WAS A POLITICAL
SCIENTIST AND RETIRED PROFESSOR
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR HE WAS MY PROFESSOR OF
CHICANA POLITICS. HE WAS BORN ON
OCTOBER THIRTY FIRST. NINETEEN
FORTY ONE IN ARTESIA CALIFORNIA
AND PASSED AWAY ON MARCH TWENTY
FIFTH. DR NEVADA'S PASSED TO
SOCIAL SERVICE BEGAN WITH
SERVING IN THE U. S. ARMY FOR
EIGHT YEARS BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN SIXTY. HE'S FIRED TO
BECOME AN OFFICER IN THE
MILITARY AND BY NINETEEN SIXTY
SEVEN HE WAS PROMOTED TO CAPTAIN
. AFTER LEAVING THE U. S. ARMY
HE EARNED A BACHELOR OF ARTS IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE FROMCLAREMONT
MEN'S COLLEGE AND A PHD IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE FROM THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. DR NEVADO BECAME AN
ACTIVISTS PROMOTING ISSUES
RELATED TO THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY DURING HIS DAYS AS A
COLLEGE STUDENT AND LATER AS A
COMMUNITY ACTIVIST. HE WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ORGANIZATION
A LOT OF ASSETS WE NEED A PARTY
IN SAN BERNARDINO AND RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. HE HAS BEEN INSTRUMENTAL
IN ORGANIZING REGIONAL
CONFERENCES AND MEETINGS TO
BRING LEADERSHIP OF THE CHICANO
COMMUNITY TOGETHER ON ISSUES
LIKE IMMIGRATION REFORM. VOTER
REGISTRATION POLICE COMMUNITY
RELATIONS CHURCH COMMUNITY
RELATIONS AND US MEXICO
RELATIONS. IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
ONE DR NEVADO SERVED AS A STATE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
FAIR REPRESENTATION A COALITION
OF OVER FIFTY CHICANA COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS IN CALIFORNIA. IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY THREE HE BECAME
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE. IN
ADDITION TO HIS POLITICAL
ACTIVITIES DR NAVARRO ALSO
TAUGHT AT VARIOUS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA WHILE
PUBLISHING SCHOLARLY ARTICLES
AND POLITICAL MANIFESTOS CALLING
FOR SOCIAL CHANGE AND POLITICAL
ACTION. DR NEVADO WAS A FIERCE
COMMUNITY ADVOCATE AND HE WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED I ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MR MEDINA THIS RAISE YOUR
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I TO RISE
TODAY ASKING THAT WE- DURING THE
MEMORY OF DR AMADO NEVADA. AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM RIVERSIDE NOTED
HE WAS A LONGTIME PROFESSOR YOU
SEE OUR UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE I WAS A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZER. USE LEFT A LASTING
IMPACT IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
THROUGH HIS WORK IN ETHNIC
STUDIES IN HIS TIRELESS ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
CHICANOS USE THAT LIST AN
EXAMPLE THAT SERVER AND ISN'T AS
AN INSPIRATION TO YOUNG CHICANOS
AND LATINOS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. THROUGH HIS EFFORTS
TO ADVOCATE FOR HIS COMMUNITY
WAS ABLE TO LEAD OPPOSITION
AGAINST GERRYMANDERING IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE THAT WOULD
HAVE DIMINISHED. THE VOTING
POWER OF LATINOS AND OTHER
MINORITY COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. AFTER THE MODEL WAS AN
IMPACTFUL AUTHOR COMPLETED FOR
COMPLETED SEVEN BOOKS AND WAS
WORKING ON HIS EIGHTH BOOK. HE
WROTE ON TOPICS REGARDING
IMMIGRATION THE PEOPLE OF
SOUTHWEST. THE MACHINE GUN ON
THE TOTAL EXPERIENCE OF OUR
PEOPLE. AND AS NOTED BY SOMEONE
EARLIER IT PANAMA IS THE HISTORY
OF OUR HISTORY. HE ALSO WROTE
ABOUT THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS AND
HIS EIGHTH BOOK WAS MEGAN KNOWS
THE EMERGING SUPERPOWER. HE
FOUNDED L. COMPLEX TO PUT UP
LEVEL SONY THOSE ALSO THE
INSTITUTE FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
THE NATIONAL INSTITUTE FOR
COMMUTATIVE ELEMENT. ALL THESE
ORGANIZATIONS CREATED TO.
FRAMEWORK FOR EVERYONE. HE WAS A
PROFESSOR AT UC ARE FOR OVER
TWENTY YEARS. HE WORKED
TIRELESSLY FROM SUNRISE TO
SUNSET. AND NOW AS HIS FAMILY
HAS SAID HE WILL REST WHILE HIS
LEGACY CONTINUES. DR NEVADA
LEAVES BEHIND HIS LONGTIME
COMPANION MUCH MARIANNE GONZALEZ
WHO WALKED ALONGSIDE HIM FOR
THIRTY FIVE YEARS HE ALSO LEAVES
BEHIND TEN. CHILDREN FIVE HIS
FIVE MARION'S. EIGHT TWENTY
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. HE WAS
UNCOMPROMISING IN HIS EFFORTS TO
EDUCATE AND CREATE A NEW
GENERATION OF LEADERS AND WHILE
HE WILL BE MISSED HIS IMPACT
WILL BE FELT FOR GENERATIONS TO
COME I ASK THAT WE ADJOURNED IN
HIS MEMORY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FRANCE MR GARCIA YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. I THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I
TO RISE. FOR THIS TO JOIN IN
MEMORY FOR DOCTOR ARE MONDO
NEVADA UC RIVERSIDE PROFESSOR OF
OVER TWENTY. PLUS YEARS. THERE
ARE A COUPLE OF THINGS THAT COME
TO MIND WHEN WE I THINK ABOUT
THE PROFESSOR- AND HIS ACTIVISM
IN THIS ACADEMIC INTELLECT. THAT
HE ADDED TO DISCUSSIONS AS IT
RELATES TO THE LATINO COMMUNITY
. THEN AND NOW IN THE COURSE OF
THE YOU KNOW LOST TRACK EIGHT
BOOKS THAT HE WROTE- DEPICTING
THE CIRCUMSTANCES THAT HAVE
EXISTED FOR. WOULD BE REFERRED
TO IN THE INTELLECTUAL CONTEXT
THE INTERNAL. COLIN INTERNALLY
COLONIZED PEOPLE OF US LINE- THE
LATINO POPULATION OF THE UNITED
STATES. I RECALL HIM VIVIDLY IN
CLASS. IT HEN IS ANIMATED. AS
WELL AS INTELLECTUAL WAY
STIMULATING THE MINDS OF MANY
YOUNG CHICANOS AND SHE GOT AS IN
OUR CLASSROOMS. TO DIG DEEP
INSIDE AND NOT ONLY. CONNECT TO
OUR AND SAYS STROLL HERITAGE.
STRUGGLES AND HOW WE COULD
UTILIZE THAT TO EMPOWER OUR OWN
COMMUNITIES THROUGH WHATEVER
PROFESSIONAL PATHWAY WE COULD.
POTENTIALLY CHOOSE TO PURSUE.
THERE ARE OVER. TEN MAYBE TWELVE
ELECTED OFFICIALS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY. THAT WALK
THROUGH THE DOORS OF DR ARMANDO
NAVARRO. THAT I SPEAK FOR ON
BEHALF OF TODAY. AND IF EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON THIS
SUBJECT IN MEMORY THEY WOULD
TELL YOU HOW PRIVILEGED. THEY
FAIL. TO HAVE HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE TAKEN A COURSE WITH
DOCTOR MON THE NEVADA ROLE
HAVING EXPERIENCED. HIS
EXPERIENCES FIRST HAND AS YOU
HEARD MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RIVERSIDE TALK ABOUT IS
EXPENSIVE HISTORY AND SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY. AND TO ACADEMIA- HE
WOULD USE THE WORDS THAT. WE
HAVE TO ORGANIZE. MOBILEYE'S AND
RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO THE WORK
THAT WE'VE SIGNED UP TO DO
PARTICULARLY THOSE IN PUBLIC
SERVICE HE WASN'T SHY OF BEING
CRITICAL OF US IN ELECTED OFFICE
FOR NOT DOING ENOUGH OR NOT
DOING MORE. FOR OUR COMMUNITIES
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH HIM IN
DECEMBER. WHAT HE CALLED TO. SAY
HAPPY HOLIDAYS- DO NOT BE AFRAID. TO PUT YOURSELF OUT THERE WHEN
IT COMES TO MAKING THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY THAT YOU'VE SIGNED UP
TO REPRESENT. ANYHOW SO
ATTEMPTED TO AGATHON TO RUN FOR
CONGRESS AND SEVEN DON'T BE
AFRAID. TO STEP OUTSIDE OF YOUR
COMFORT ZONE. AND MAKE A
DECISION TO. TAKE THE WORK THAT
YOU'VE DONE TO THE NEXT LEVEL. I
DIDN'T TAKE THAT ADVICE. BUT I
TOOK A WHOLE LONG LIST OF OTHER
. THINGS THAT HE ADVISED US ON
FROM THE MOMENT WE WALKED INTO
HIS CLASS IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS. TO THE MOMENT THAT I
RAN FOR OFFICE FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN MY ARRIVAL TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE AND
I CAN. TELL YOU THAT- DOCTOR
MONDO NEVADA ROLE. EVEN ON A
RISK RECENT TRIP TO MEXICO CITY
AND MEETING WITH OFFICIALS.
TALKING ABOUT BY CULTURAL BY
NATIONAL ISSUES- THEY REMEMBER
DR NEVADO IN MEXICO CITY FOR THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE WORK. THAT
HE HAS. PUT FORWARD AND THAT IS
IN HIS EIGHT BOOKS AND HE NEVER
WAS SHY OF TALI KNOWS HOW MANY
BOOKS HE HAD WRITTEN. AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE- NATION'S.
LATINO COMMUNITY. AND THE
PROMINENCE. THAT WE PLAY. WHEN
IT COMES TO THE DECISION MAKING
. NOT JUST IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THROUGHOUT THE NATION AND SO I'M
YOU KNOW SAD AND BUT ALSO.
HONORED TO BE ABLE TO SPEAK ON
THIS FLOOR IN THE TURN IN THE
JOURNAL OF HIS MEMORIES OF THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU MR GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK. THANK
YOU MADAM SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO REQUEST THAT WE ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF OUR IN THE UNDER
FORMER UNITED STATES CONGRESS
CONGRESSMAN THE SEVEN TAURUS. MR
TAURUS WAS BORN ON JANUARY
TWENTY SEVENTH NINETEEN THIRTY
IN ARIZONA. AT THE AGE OF FIVE
HIS FATHER WAS DEPORTED NEVER TO
BE HEARD FROM AGAIN. ENSURE
EITHER AFTER HIS MOTHER MOVED
THEIR FAMILY TO LOS ANGELES.
FOLLOWING HIGH SCHOOL FIRST
SERVED IN THE U. S. ARMY DURING
THE KOREAN WAR WE'RE UPON HIS
RETURN HE BEGAN WORKING AS AN
ASSEMBLY LINE WORKER AT THE
CHRYSLER PLANT IN MAY WOULD
CALIFORNIA. EVENTUALLY TAURUS
WOULD JOIN THE UNITED AUTO
WORKERS AND ROSE THROUGH THE
RANKS QUICKLY. SERVING AS AN
ORGANIZER FOR THE WESTERN REGION
OF THE UNITED STATES AS THE UAW
INTERNATIONAL REPRESENTATIVE IN
WASHINGTON DC. I'M FROM NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR TO NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT HE WOULD BECOME UAW'S
INTER AMERICAN BUREAU OF
CARIBBEAN AND LATIN AMERICAN
AFFAIRS. IN ADDITION TO HIS WORK
WITH THE U. A. W. TAURUS FOUNDED
THE EAST LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY
UNION. KNOWN AS TELUGU A
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION SERVING AS ITS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR UNTIL
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOR. HIS
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE U. A. W.
AND THE ESTABLISHMENT OF TELUGU
PROVIDED A PLATFORM FOR HIS
SUCCESSFUL CONGRESSIONAL CAREER
BEGINNING IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
THREE. HIS SERVICE WAS
HIGHLIGHTED BY HIS REPUTATION AS
A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR WORKING
CLASS AMERICANS UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES AND VETERANS. HE WAS
WIDELY ADMIRED AND HIS COUNSEL
WAS REGULARLY SOUGHT BY
DEMOCRATIC AND REPUBLICAN
LEADERS FROM THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY. TAURUSES SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE R. C. AND THE FIVE
CHILDREN CARMEN RINA CAMILLE
SELENA AND STEVE. MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT WE
ADJOURNED TODAY IN THE MEMORY OF
FORMER UNITED STATES CONGRESSMAN
AS SEVENTY TWO HOURS IT TORRANCE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RUBIO. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CIRCUMVENT THIS YEAR RECOGNIZED
AT YOUR DESK. THANK YOU MADAM
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I RISE TODAY
TO ASK THE ASSEMBLY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY A CONGRESSMAN
ESTEBAN TORRES OF WEST COVINA
WHO PASSED AWAY IN JANUARY. HE
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE R. C.
FIVE CHILDREN TWELVE
GRANDCHILDREN AND SEVEN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN. MANY OF YOU
ALREADY KNOW THE HIGHLIGHTS OF
CONGRESSMAN TOWARDS THIS CAREER
HEPERSONIFIED THE NOT BE A
PUBLIC SERVICE. THE SON OF
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS A LABOR
LEADER WITH THE UNITED AUTO
WORKERS UNITED STATES AMBASSADOR
TO UNESCO IN A SPECIAL ASSISTANT
TO PRESIDENT JIMMY CARTER. AND
THE TRAILBLAZING LATINO MEMBER
OF THE CONGRESS FOR CALL FOR
NEARLY TWENTY YEARS WHO ALSO
SERVED AS CHAIR OF THE
CONGRESSIONAL HISPANIC CAUCUS.
BUT THE REASONS I RISE TODAY ON
THIS FLOOR IS THAT CONGRESSMAN
TORE AS WAS A DEAR FRIEND OF MY
FAMILY. WHEN MY FATHER WERE
SERVING IN STUDENT GOVERNMENT I
UC RIVERSIDE. CHRISTMANN TAURUS
TOOK HIM UNDER HIS WING. MY DAD
A LOT CONGRESSMAN THOREZ- IT ON
HIS HAND OUR JOURNEY. AND HE WAS
ELECTED TO THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND LATER. AS AN
AID IN THE CONGRESSMAN'S
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICE AS A MENTOR
TO MY FAMILY CONGRESSMAN TOWARDS
WAS A CONSTANT PRESENCE ARE
LIGHT. I WAS HONORED. THAT MY
FATHER AND I ATTENDED THE
CONGRESSMAN'S FUNERAL- EARLY
THIS YEAR. OUR PRESENCE. NOT.
FAMILY BY FAMILIES THIS GREAT
FOR OUR COMMUNITY AND TO OUR
ENTIRE STATE. CALLING IS VERY I
RISE TO. AND NOW THESE ADJOURNED
AND THE MEMBER KERR. ESTEBAN
TORRES. THANK YOU MISTER AROUND
THIS ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM SPEAKER MEMBER MY
HEART BREAKS- TO PROVIDE OR TO
SPEAK ON THIS ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY I RISE TODAY TO ASK HIS
BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
TWO BEAUTIFUL SOULS. THAT WERE
TAKEN AWAY FROM US FAR TOO SOON
. ON THE EVENING OF MARCH THE
FIRST. OF THIS YEAR JOSE PLOTS
HILLS FORTY TWO YEARS OLD. AND
HIS DAUGHTER SAMANTHA. THREE
YEARS OLD WERE ASLEEP IN THEIR
APARTMENT ON THE FIRST FLOOR
WHEN A DRUNK DRIVER STE LOST
CONTROL OF HIS TRUCK AND STRUCK
THE BUILDING. BEDROOM WHERE THE
TWO HAD LAID ASLEEP. THE
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SON- HEY JESS
GOT UP TO GO USE THE BATHROOM.
AND AVOID IT THIS SITUATION JOSE
AND SAMANTHA WAS IS SURVIVED BY
HIS WIFE. MS BLASIO AND SUN. IT
PAINS ME TO MAKE THIS ADJOURNED
IN MEMORY TODAY IT PAINS ME
BECAUSE THE LITTLE LITTLE
SAMANTHA WAS JUST A TODDLER.
WHEN SHE WAS TRAGICALLY STRUCT.
IT PAINS ME BECAUSE JOSE
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO HIS FAMILY
. HE WORKED HARD TO SHOW THEM-
WITH LOVE AND COMPASSION AS A
FATHER IT PAINS ME BECAUSE JOSE
WAS A GIRL DAD. THERE IS NO BOND
LIKE A FATHER HAVE WITH ITS
DAUGHTERS. THEREIS NOTHING
STRONGER THAN A FAMILY BUILT BY
LOVE. LET ME DESCRIBE THAT LOVE
JOSE AND HIS LOVELY WIFE LOVE
EACH OTHER VERY DEARLY. JOSE AND
HIS WIFE WS BOTH BORN IN A
SMALL TOWN IN MEXICO- THE STATE
OF DORADO. THEY MET IN HIGH
SCHOOL BUT WERE SEPARATED WHEN
JOSE DECIDED TO FOLLOW HIS
SISTER TO WORK IN CALIFORNIA
ALTHOUGH YOU ALTHOUGH PHYSICALLY
SEPARATED JOSE AND HIS WIFE
RELATIONSHIP BLOSSOMED. THEY
WROTE ALMOST EACH AND EVERY DAY
LETTERS TO ONE ANOTHER AND WAS
ABLE TO SPEAK ON THE PHONE ON
OCCASIONS IN TWO THOUSAND FOUR.
MS PELOS CO JOINED JOSE IN THE
UNITED STATES WITH A MARRIED AND
FOUND THEIR HOME IN LONG BEACH
CALIFORNIA. MIZZOU'S PLOWS YO
SAY THAT SHE CAN SHE CAN'T- SHE
CAN REMEMBER ANYTIME WHERE A
HUSBAND DID NOT WORK EACH AND
EVERY DAY IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
FOR HER AND HER FAMILY. HE
WORKED. AT A MEAT MARKET AND A
ROOF INSTALLER TO PROVIDE FOR
HIS FAMILY HE DEDICATED HIS LIFE
TO HIS FAMILY HE SPOILED THEM.
EVERY CHANCE WITH THE TRIP OR
GIVE SOMEWHERE THAT HE CAN
AFFORD. THIS IS AN UNSPEAKABLE
TRAGEDY THAT SCREAMS OUT FOR
JUSTICE TODAY THE PLOTS HILLS
FAMILY TRIED TO CARRY ON. AND
REYES HONOR TO THEIR MEMORY OF
SAMANTHA AND ALSO JOSE AND SHARE
THEIR STORIES. ABOUT THE TWO.
MEMBERS THE INDIVIDUAL WHO DID
THIS IS STILL SOMEWHERE. OUT
THERE HAS NEVER BEEN CAUGHT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
FLORIDA TO THE JOURNEY'S MEMORY
OF THE PLOTS HILLS FAMILY JOSE
AND SAMANTHA WHO SHOULD BE WITH
US WE ASK THIS BODY ADJOURNED IN
THEIR MEMORY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO ADJOURN
IN THE MEMORY OF OLIVER TAYLOR
HAWKINS HUCKINS WAS THE HARD
HITTING CHARISMATIC DRUMMER AT
THE FOO FIGHTERS HIS SUDDEN
PASSING AT THE AGE OF FIFTY HAS
BEEN MOURNED BY MUSIC FANS ALL
AROUND THE GLOBE. TAYLOR AND THE
FOO FIGHTERS WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A WORLDWIDE TOUR AND HAD BEEN
SCHEDULED TO PERFORM A SHOW IN
COLUMBIA. HOW CAN STARTED TO
PLAY THE DRUMS AND HE WAS JUST
TEN YEARS OLD AND HE HAS SAID
THAT HIS MOTHER GAVE HIM THE
CONFIDENCE TO DREAM BIG. WHEN I
FIRST GOT DRUMS SHE WAS THE ONE
WHO WOULD WATCH ME PLAY SHE WAS
A BIG SUPPORTER AND TOLD ME I'D
MAKE IT HE SAID IN AN INTERVIEW
LAST YEAR. MAKE IT HE CERTAINLY
TO IT FOLLOWING HIS BREAKOUT IN
THE MID NINETIES DRUMMING FOR
LANUS MORISSETTE. THE OTHER JOIN
THE FOO FIGHTERS IN NINETEEN
NINETY NINE. BAND WENT ON TO WIN
TWELVE GRAMMYS AND JUST LAST
YEAR WERE INDUCTED INTO THE ROCK
AND ROLL HALL OF FAME. TAYLOR
WAS MORE THAN A ROCK STAR AND HE
IS REMEMBERED AS A GENEROUS AND
GENUINE PERSON. A TRUE AND LOYAL
FRIEND IN HIS MEMOIR THE STORY
TELLER THE FUSE DAVE GROHL
DESCRIBED HAWKINS AS HIS BEST
FRIEND AND PARTNER IN CRIME. SO
MANY BRIGHTENED UP ROOMS WITH
HIS BODILY PRESENCE AND A
CONSTANT CHEEKY GRIN. AND EVEN
AS HE FOUND WORLDWIDE FAME WITH
THE FOO FIGHTERS TAYLOR REMAINED
PART OF THE CLOSE KNIT LAGUNA
BEACH COMMUNITY WHERE HE GREW
UP. HEATHER GRADUATED FROM
LAGUNA BEACH HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN NINETY AND WHILE HIS
DRUMS WOULD TAKE HIM ALL AROUND
THE WORLD. HEATHER COULD STILL
OFTEN BE FOUND ON OUR LOCAL
BEACHES AND IN THE MOUNTAINS
AROUND THE GONNA. SURFING
MOUNTAIN BIKING AND SPENDING
TIME WITH HIS TIGHT GROUP OF
LONGTIME FRIENDS. MISTER HAWKINS
IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE ALISON
AND THEIR THREE CHILDREN. OLIVER
ANNABELLE AND EVERLY. AS HAPPENS
WHEN WE LOSE SOMEONE TOO SOON
HIS FAMILY BANDMATES FRIENDS AND
FANS ARE ALL STRUGGLING TO MAKE
SENSE OF THIS LOSS MAY HIS
MEMORY BE A BLESSING AND TO MAKE
HIS MUSIC AND HIS LEGACY BE AN
INSPIRATION FOR ARTISTS IN
GENERATIONS TO COME. THANK YOU
WAS PITCHING NORTH WAS WHEN YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED AT YOUR DESK.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO ALSO
ASKED TO RETURN IN MEMORY OF ALL
OVER TAYLOR HAWKINS OF LAGUNA
BEACH- UNEXPECTEDLY PASSED AWAY
ON FRIDAY MARCH TWENTY FIFTH TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO AT THE AGE
OF FIFTY. HE WAS BORN ON
FEBRUARY SEVENTEENTH NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO IN FORT WORTH TEXAS
TO TERRY AND ELIZABETH HAWKINS.
TAYLOR'S FAMILY MOVED TO LAGUNA
BEACH IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
WHERE HE LAID A GRADUATE FROM
THE GOING BEACH HIGH SCHOOL IN
NINETEEN NINETY. HIS PARENTS
BOUGHT HIM A DRUM KIT WHEN HE
WAS TEN YEARS OLD SETTING INTO
MOTION A LIFE LOVE THE LIFELONG
LOVE OF MUSIC AND AWARD WINNING
CAREER THAT SPANNED OVER TWENTY
YEARS. WHAT IS LOVE OF PLAYING
DRUMS. HE BEGAN TO PERFORM WITH
LOCAL GROUPS AND IN NINETEEN
NINETY FIVE WAS RECRUITED TO
PLAY WITH ALANIS MORISSETTE.
DURING HER TOUR. DURING THAT
TIME HE ALSO BECAME FRIENDS WITH
DAVE GROHL FOUNDER OF THE FOO
FIGHTERS TAYLOR JOINED THE BAND
IN NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN WHERE
HE REMAINED THE DRUMMER A SINGER
AND A SONGWRITER AND TO HIS
DEATH HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
ALISON AND THEIR THREE CHILDREN
ALL OVER. ANNABEL AND EVERY LEAF
. MY THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS ARE
WITH THE HAWKINS FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND ALSO TO THE FAMILY
AND FRIENDS IN LAGUNA BEACH IN
THE COMMUTER OF THE CAN YOU
BEACH IS DIFFICULT TIME THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS WHEN MEMBERS
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES TO THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST TO ADJOURN
IN MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
MOVING ON TO THE SESSION
SCHEDULE. WHICH IS AS FOLLOWS
TUESDAY APRIL NINETEENTH CHECK
IN SESSION. WEDNESDAY APRIL
TWENTIETH CHECK IN SESSION
THURSDAY APIL TWENTY FIRST.
FLOOR SESSION AT NINE AM. IN
ADJOURNMENT ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED
RETAINED ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER. MYSTERY AS SOMEONE
MOVES. MISCARRY OF SECONDS THAT
THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL THURSDAY APRIL TWENTY
FIRST AT NINE AM.